[Music]
let's
talk about sex baby let's talk about
you and me let's talk about all the good
things
all the bad things that maybe let's talk
about eh
sex money drugs
let's talk about rich people no
i don't want to talk about money draw
your tears draw your tears
no we talking about rich people problems
uh no i just like talking about rich
people because it's so like a rich [ __ ]
so far away from what my reach is i do
like talking about rich people love
talking about rich people
like forbes magazine like the the top
whatever top 40 or whatever yeah it
almost feels like i'm in another world
like watching like
i feel like a 1950s wife that's like oh
honey wouldn't it be great
if we lived in this world like you know
i
i transferred myself into a soul of a
step
step step forward housewife or whatever
like that cookie cutter
you make a good wife yeah and in that in
that soul
i tell i'm talking to my husband a
little bit and i'm talking to my husband
and my kids and like
oh dear wouldn't it be wonderful
wouldn't it be a dream come true if we
were rich
and we lived his life i'm like yes
darling yes yeah what
what is the concept of rich for you like
what is what what number
do you do someone does someone have to
hit before you're like
that person's [ __ ] it's not a number
it's a life it's a lifestyle you're
walking through a beautiful field
full of fruits not bad that's soy tea
and so far
yeah and i walked through that's soy tea
so far i walk through a nicely paved
hallway
and it's hanging with mangoes and
watermelon
we're still outdoors or is this indoors
no no no it's i'm painting a picture
into my property okay indoors
outdoors this is your property casey's
asking what you think is rich
how do you answer your question so when
i grow mangoes right
[Laughter]
and then you walk in and you're greeted
i'm picturing like oversight
yes but it's it's fruits and vegetables
not not a garden
that's just pointless leaves okay you
can pick off of it
that's real wealth i mean like you're
imagine walking into somebody's house
and you [ __ ] pick a fresh mango out
and you just eat that this mango tree
won't even have leaves it would just
have mangoes that's it and everyone's
butt naked too but with one leaf just
right here
we'll get to that you harden it back
right always
and then you go over there yeah we're in
ambassador there's a bunch of
beautiful girls and really micro bikinis
he covers the whole breast but the
nipples that would be a joe thing
covers everything but the nipple yeah i
like covering the nose i haven't seen
that yet
that's funny dominatrix too it's just
the nipples cut out tassels
no no no no no no no oh yeah
everything's covered oh that's kind of
nice
i would do like maybe a mini tank top
that shows the belly but then you
have the areolas cut out oh wait what no
you lost me there
like y'all's tank top but instead of it
covering the boob it just goes
wearing it backwards it goes out and
then the tits are coming out like that
on the side
that would be kind of cool because i was
like
with that description i don't know if
anyone's ever reached it that's rich
you didn't get to the point where when
you squeeze the boobs just dollar bills
come out
that's pretty rich no no and then you
walk through the atm machine and then
they all have spears right because if
you try to touch them
they'll kill your ass right they're only
for you
maybe if they want to with consent with
consent because i'm not that kind of guy
all right so we're friends but it's with
consent i don't [ __ ] my employees okay
so we walk through and then there's a
mountain
of gold and behind that there is three
mud huts
oh jesus so only this is considered rich
for you yes
three mud huts and a mountain of gold
but you have a hallway where's this
hallway
it's a it's like a garden a hallway it's
a garden hall it's like a path yeah yeah
like palace oversized like that you
gotta go through that
mango trees everywhere when you get to
the end there's just a big
[ __ ] pile of gold like the goonies
scene you know when they got into the
cave
and it's just a [ __ ] ton of rubies and
gold and treasure
from every [ __ ] era and that is
ballin because
that's that's like a billion dollars or
something
so regardless of all the other variables
giant pile of gold
you can throw all the chicks away throw
the mingles away
like duck tales it's mainly just been
gold a lot
why did you start with joe you see what
happened no okay
let's start let's go over here that's
probably the richest idea here
true you guys are gonna have some basic
ones watch you can't top well mine's
lower i mean mine's like i'm actually
gonna answer casey's question
what is it i think someone if someone
has like eight figures
i think that's rich okay that's that's i
would say that
but that's not rich with love that's
just rich with money well that's his
question oh 100 million
no 10 million if you hit 10 million
that's eight figures yeah yeah every
time i hear figures i'm like okay do we
count
that no no that doesn't you don't count
the cents no you don't have zero
what about 12 figures oh my god for me
100 million i'm like
[ __ ] rich like can you say [ __ ]
rich no but 12
there's one man that's finally hit 200
jeff bezos
200. he's the first one billion first
one
ever heyman zuckerberg going to be the
first trillionaires right uh
i don't know i know okay so the reason
why i brought up these rich guys and i
want to talk about this guys is so fun
because it's like a race for them i feel
like they're like they're like
looking at each other like i'm going to
be number one i'm being number one no
it's crazy though it's a race to a thing
that i can't even grasp anymore yeah
it's like so far beyond it before when
there was like a race to like
billionaire
ism i'm like oh [ __ ] they're gonna get
there and then when you think about like
wars right like they're like trillion
dollar like
operations so i'm like [ __ ] war is
[ __ ] crazy
but now a single person is going into
the trillionaire territory and i'm like
[ __ ] is this fool's like
inside of his house like on his ceiling
fan or just like four
jets just flying and [ __ ] like how are
they spending money right
billions already like i don't know what
to do and then
how do they calculate that is it because
like they're they're calculating like
amazon's net worth yeah the value of the
of of
of his ass stocks it's not it's not like
he's got 200 billion in cash
like no i didn't think he would have
cash but then i'm just wondering like
how and then his baseball cards how much
they worth and they add it all to they
added on it
yeah his car collection baseball card
does that not include his ex-wife
trees on his house yeah because they
should take a good chunk because his
ex-wife is like 67 billion right yeah
she's number one now
in terms of female billionaire she
passed all brown
yeah she's rich she passed the l'oreal
the
l'oreal uh lady like just by being a
freeloader
damn no she helped build that company
too
so bezos right
i have nothing to worry about you're
korean i ain't nothing you don't even
know what you're talking about
that's a different video because i got
nothing to worry about
so bezos was working he's off to sleep
roughly 115 billion at the beginning of
this year 115 billion but because of
kovid
it helps amazon just be everyone going
to amazon
to buy stuff and whatnot we're trying to
stay indoors
the the the share price of of of uh
of amazon is 3441.85
and so for the number of shares that he
has for amazon it's ballooned them up to
billion dollars now so dude he unloaded
and bought it back you know that right
i did not know that because he he he was
able to that is
[ __ ] that's genius he timed the whole
thing i think he unloaded it
right before we hit quarantine he was in
on it you think he was in on it [ __ ]
yeah you probably got insider knowledge
somehow
dirty i was gonna get it at 600. i know
i think so i didn't get any
dang got a [ __ ] and forgot it all
was it worth it yeah okay then you win
imagine
making 90 billion dollars in less than a
year i
can't 90 billion dollars that is good i
have a rat brain
90 million so 90 billion
exactly like i don't know where the
difference is do you think it's
obviously there's a difference have you
seen a scale of
the difference between a million and a
billion that already
it's like a mountain it's like dubai
tower versus like
a single resident home damn right that
if you stack the money up i'm i'm
exaggerating but it's that's my
brain to try to think of most normal
hundred people yeah i don't i'm not even
thinking about like the
how the money looks i'm just thinking
about lifestyle changes from
nothing 100 million to 100 billion do
you think there's no lifestyle
oh there is life to all right i thought
you meant 100 million i mean 100 billion
to 200 billion
that won't be nothing but the 100
million like say like
uh who's the famous hundred millionaire
conor mcgregor 100 millionaire
but then you got [ __ ] are you about
to call him mcgregor too so this is what
this is what i
read in like uh like a forbes magazine
they said uh 10 millionaires which is
eight figure people
they uh fly in like private jets and
stuff 100 millionaires are the ones that
own the actual plane like jackie chan
like they own the plan they own the jet
billionaire i don't even know they might
own a fleet they might own the land they
might own the airline
air oh the air yeah the air will be
flying through my air space
like a personal airline they own a
personal airline and they own
yachts that cost like a hundred million
by
themselves or some [ __ ] that's not even
their house it's just that they're both
and then they don't even go on it and
these yachts are just
droplets yeah it's kind of like the
crews that we went on but just for that
guy what do you think what do you think
is easier to imagine
us imagining having a billion dollars or
bezels like imagining what it is like
live like us right now he knows
he's been through it though did you see
that janky ass picture of him spray
painting amazon on the [ __ ]
wall and then he oh man he looked like a
dirty geek how's this marketing yes good
morning
but yeah so bezos is number one he's so
within this year he surpassed uh what's
his name
uh i'm looking at bill gates yeah bill
gates he's
worth 116 billion so basil's just a
million
underneath or a billion underneath him
and then within this year now he's like
got this far ass like uh spread on him
now
and uh who knew i also read that elon
musk
surpassed zuckerberg and in third place
is elon musk now and he recently
surpassed zuckerberg and zuckerberg's at
number four now
so unfollows freaking out i don't know i
i don't
i don't even know what they're thinking
like no they have to care
it's a race right no they have to care
think about it if that's the
you're not in any other rat race because
you're not like yo i gotta make money
blah blah so there's only one last
rat race and it's like oh i'm in a top
five of something in the world
i don't know why would you not want to
advance
yeah i never cared how many subscription
subscribers i had but we've never been
in the top five either that's true when
you're
maybe when you're top it did it's
different i think if you're top three
and you get bumped down to four
that's saying something
what matters to them is probably way
different than what matters to us
you know so what matters to them what
about matt what matters to them
is like feeding kids right
all over the world i feel like they have
a little bit of that i mean
i got god like money yeah now let me
feed the world
sure true i mean i'm a fan of elon for
reasons like that
elon i think is like that for sure like
i i feel like i know a lot of like feed
the world or he's like [ __ ] this well
i'm like yeah
but like he's he's definitely about
improving the world he's definitely
improving humanity deserving humanity
and continuing it
like if that full made food to be so
[ __ ] high-tech people i didn't want
to eat that [ __ ] but he would also troll
it too
he'll be like bad food come back it's
like soylent that he's [ __ ] sending
to everyone
elon wouldn't be afraid to sacrifice
like 50 of like humanity in order to
progress it
i'm down with that too but what if
you're a part of that 50 then i needed
to go
dang elon's the rapture you're
sacrificial you let him be
god to you not me i'll be i'll kill you
long [ __ ] that
you trying to kill me [ __ ] but
you're just a waste in his eyes so do
you want to progress humanity or do you
want to set it back i i want to progress
society the way i see fit and i'll kill
that [ __ ] for trying to kill me
that's a pretty
like reasonable answer yeah it is yeah i
guess i should do the same thing
fight back i don't think i could get to
him what the [ __ ]
but you wouldn't be alone in that
thinking so you you could create an army
like with anthony
can we use ken just for this because i
don't think jk is up for it we're
[ __ ] dance pacifist man we fight with
our battles
no that's you guys probably get access
to doing a show
and then all i need is you guys oh like
a mogado move
i'll do the theme i'll do it you have
more of a chance
of performing for elon you know instead
of
no live performances during kobit no but
like you know when
he's telling you no in a polite way he
doesn't want to go home because this is
what's going to happen
too bad we're going to use changes well
this is what's going to happen oh okay
this is not a formal threat i just want
to let elon know
kendra's is not formally doing anything
no you're going to perform joe
on the other hand he does not watch jk
news
somebody send elon this link how i'm
going to assassinate his ass
why am i in this is going to perform
i'm going to be dancing as a kinja and
when we
he takes your name
when i hand him a rose what am i going
to do just like joe to try and blame him
and when he grabs the rose his poison
two seals kiss from a rose
nice that would be really good actually
yep
and then he's gonna smell the rose and
go oh now i can't kill humanity
no but then little did you know he had
some special plugs in his nostrils to
prevent
poison from entering then i'll try
another move i'll come back later
true he's probably got like we're going
to be like 10 clones of himself
no he's already never loaded to the
nearest yeah you killed my body
oh yeah he probably is yeah he might
even already be in mars or some [ __ ]
you'll never get to the real elon musk
[ __ ] like rick and morty like you can
never kill rick
you see his hairline like his old hair
is balding
and then now it's like a rich set of
hair i mean he's that's technology huh
he's defying all kinds of [ __ ] elon but
i thought he meant rick
for a second and i was like i guess he
has that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you